hello everyone welcome to simply learn
today we will be doing a machine
learning interactive quiz
before we get started i hope the screen
is clearly visible and the audio is fine
so if there are any shoes please type in
yes do let us know in the chat section
so that we can resolve them
i'm repeating again if there are any
issues please type in yes do let us know
in the chat section so that we can
resolve them
i hope this screen is clearly visible
and the audio is fine
if there are any issues please type in
yes
do let us know in the chat section so
that we can resolve them
i and above
hi bumit
low nk
so i see a lot of positive response
great
let's wait for some time for others to
join
hello suraj
i think we can get started
so hello everyone i am from simply learn
welcome to today's quiz on machine
learning we will be starting with our
quiz soon
before we will take a small precap into
the world of machine learning and where
the world is moving forward in regards
to it
stay tuned until the end of the quiz for
a chance to win amazon vouchers
if you are among the top three winners
don't forget to send their screenshot
from your respective email id to
youtube contest
simplylearn.net i'm repeating again
youtube contest at simplylearn.net
that being said
let's learn a little bit more about the
state of machine learning in 2022
machine learning is a subpart of
artificial intelligence
broadly defined as a machine's
capability to imitate intelligent human
behavior
like humans learn from their past and
acquire knowledge through experience
either directly or shared by others
machine acquired knowledge through
experience shared in the form of the
data
machine learning is becoming
increasingly important in our daily
lives
identification of trends and patterns
automation predicting of weather
predictive analysis and many other
applications you utilize machine
learning
machine learning is classified into four
parts
supervised
unsupervised
reinforcement and semi-supervised
teen learning is no longer for a science
fiction concept
there are 1.41 billion industry
that is already upgrading the way we
comprehend and use enormous information
for various uses
machine learning and ai have the
potential to disrupt and improve our
current process in almost every area of
society from assisting cutting-edge
cancer research to assisting businesses
in tracking their inventory
knowingly or unknowingly machine
learning is playing a major role in our
day-to-day life
here are some machine learning
application
that will prove
how machine learning is helping everyone
all over the globe
we all use youtube netflix facebook in
our daily lives
the machine learning algorithm figure
out the patterns of what type of video
movie you watch and thus provide this
suggestion accordingly
is one of the best companies which
manufactures self-driving cars using
electric
solar and integrated renewable energy
solutions
cars by tesla are already making their
way to the market
and are ready to show the world of power
of ai and machine learning
another application of machine learning
is speech recognition
we are all aware of voice assistance
like
siri by apple cortana by microsoft and
alexa by amazon
these assistant translate is piece to
text and use machine learning to provide
results
machine learning is also used in medical
sector to determine various diseases
with the help of machine learning
the pattern and symptoms of disease can
be easily diagnosed
weather forecasting and financial
forecasting are other applications of
machine learning in which future
outcomes are predicted using historical
data
it involves the use of statical modeling
data mining techniques and machine
learning for prediction
if you are prepared to infuse machine
learning into your cooperative strategy
and offer a specialized experience
check out simply learn machine learning
certification course which covers all
the concept of machine learning while
following a flexible schedule to suit
your needs
it covers the types of machine learning
along with the time series modeling and
practice projects to solidify your
foundation before you can earn the
certificate i'm repeating again if you
are prepared to infuse machine learning
into your corporate strategy and offer
specialized experience check out simply
learn machine learning certification
course which covers all the concept of
machine learning while following a
flexible statute to suit your needs
you can also opt for the free skill up
course which provides you the basic
knowledge of machine learning
with just 6 hours of training and
certification to board with it
you can get ready to tackle your first
ml work experience with panic
with the salaries of machine learning
trained professional projected to grow
up by 38 percent the time is type to up
skill yourself will simply learn and
accelerate your career today i'm
repeating again the time is life to up
skill yourself with some plan and
accelerate your career today
take part in the quiz it is highly
recommended to use your mobile phone
to visit the website www.menti.com
and use the code 46337129
or being shown on the screen now
you can also use a different tab on your
browser to take part in the quiz
but our live stream will be broadcasting
the result as soon as the answers are
given by the participants
so it is beneficial to have both screen
visible
at the same time
once you open the link and input the
code
just wait for the quiz to start
and be ready to answer the questions
the faster you respond the more and more
points you earn so
think quickly and click quickly
i'm repeating again to take part in the
quiz it is highly recommended to use
your mobile phone to visit the website
www.menti.com
and use the code 46337129
or being shown in the screen now
you can also use different tab on your
browser to take part in the quiz
but our live stream will be broadcasting
the result as soon as the answers are
given by the participants so it is
beneficial to have both the screen
visible at the same time
once you open the link and input the
code just wait for the quiz to start and
be ready to answer the question
the faster you respond and the more and
more points you want so
think quickly and click quickly
high power
you can also use a different tab on your
browser to take part in the quiz but our
live stream will be broadcasting the
result as soon as the answers are given
by the participant so it is beneficial
to have both screen visible at the same
time
once you open the link and input the
code just wait for the quiz to start and
be ready to answer the question the
faster you respond the more and more
points you want so
think quickly and click quickly
so
i guess
we have enough folks so we can
so let's get the party started
conserve fast to get more and more
points so question number first is what
is machine learning
i'm repeating again what is machine
learning option a the selective
acquisition of knowledge through the use
of computer
option b selected knowledge acquisition
through the use of normal program
option c the autonomous acquisition of
knowledge through the use of computer
program option d autonomous knowledge
acquisition through this use of manual
programs
five second left hurry up what is
machine learning
so times is up so let's see
seven folks gave the correct answer
so
the simulation of human intelligence
function by machines particularly
computer system is known as artificial
intelligence and machine learning expert
system natural language processing
speech recognition machine vision are
some examples of specific ml
applications
let's move on the leaderboard and see
the positioning of the forks
gave the fastest answer
74 and raj kumar b